a lot going on on Capitol Hill day the
circus came to town president's former
lawyer Michael Cohen testified for most
the daylight hours
everybody carried it you probably heard
snippets in the Ebor on the way to work
you've got a real job so we watched
every moment because we're paid to do
that and most the day was devoted to the
question of Trump's personal character
now people in Washington never tire of
being shocked by what an incredibly bad
man Donald Trump is they're incredibly
good people and they can just hardly
believe his flaws
they sat open-mouthed in the Congress
today as Michael Cohen described his
former boss brace ourselves now as a bit
of a con man who has it times overstated
his personal wealth in private Trump
apparently has said offensive things at
one point Michael Cohen claims Trump
used a straw buyer to bid up a portrait
of himself at a charity auction he
wanted his picture to go for the highest
price whoa are you shocked yet can you
believe it of course you can this is
exactly the man we knew back in 2015
when he descended the famous escalator
and yet millions of people voted for him
anyway his character was not the point
the point of today's hearings was not
his character either it was supposed to
be Russian collision and obstruction of
justice those the topics that have
completely derailed the American
government for the past two years and on
those subjects we actually did learn
quite a bit today here's one example
about a month ago the cat blog BuzzFeed
ran an article that claimed Trump had
ordered Michael Cohen to lie to the
Congress that's a big deal it's a crime
and so immediately the hysterics in the
Congress and on cable news went bonkers
impeachment indictment life in prison
but did that actually happen
well since Cohen was there in person he
was able to conclusively answer that
question today and he did watch mr.
Cohen you stood before multiple
congressional committees before today
and raise your right hand and swore an
oath to be honest is that correct that
is correct and you lied to those
congressional committees is that correct
previously correct yes sir
you stated that Trump never directed you
to lie to Congress is that correct
that's correct
okay so it looks like Trump will not be
going to jail for suborning perjury
after all
darn coiled again look for a retraction
in your latest edition of BuzzFeed
you'll find it just below the 15 cats
that look like Ruth Bader Ginsburg
listicle look carefully but what about
Russian blackmail you've been hearing
about that for years Trump they have
told you again and again has somehow
been compromised
by the Russians and that's why he's been
spying for them Putin has something
horrible in incriminating on Donald
Trump he must a picture the president in
a Batman costume maybe or a videotape
with hookers doing something weird
certainly Michael Cohen would know about
that kind of thing that's his world
luckily a sitting member of Congress
asked Cohen about it directly today
watch are you aware of anything that the
president has done at home or abroad
that may have subjected him to or may
subject him to extortion or blackmail I
am not know okay are you aware of any
videotapes that may be the subject of
extortion or blackmail I've heard about
these tapes for a long time I've had
many people contact me over the years I
have no reason to believe that that tape
exists the great Jamie Raskin of
suburban Maryland the ladies and
gentlemen thanks mr. Raskin for clearing
that up so the P tape is not real there
goes the GC Esparta the Trump dossier
what you'll remember was yet another
highly publicized scoop from yes
BuzzFeed
could it be time to get back to those
cat videos fellows but wait what about
the trip to Prague that Michael Cohen's
supposedly took that was part of his
collusion with the dark forces of the
Russian Empire that was in the dossier
as well BuzzFeed told us about it
Shirley Cohen would admit it now he's
heading to prison he's got nothing to
lose well Cohen was asked about that
Prague trip today and here's what he
said you have been to Prague
I've never been to Prague never I have
I've never been to the Czech Republic
you might bounce my time this is where
it gets confusing never been to Prague
this is the point at which what they
call the narrative starts to break down
a little bit if Michael Cohen never went
to Prague
as BuzzFeed and Adam Schiff and the
entire primetime lineup of MSNBC have
told us repeatedly that he did that how
exactly did Michael Cohen collude with
the Russians to steal the 2016
presidential election from its rightful
winner Hillary Clinton well that's a
good question isn't it debbie Wasserman
Schultz of Florida as incisive and
interviewers the Democrats have wondered
that too here's the exchange based on
what you know would mr. Trump or did he
lie about colluding and coordinating
with the Russians at any point during
the campaign so as I stated in my
testimony I wouldn't use the word
colluding was there something odd about
the back-and-forth praise with President
Putin yes but I'm not really sure that I
can answer that question in terms of
collusion oh wait so there's no cohesion
there's no Russian blackmail there's no
obstruction of justice there none of the
things that our entire media class has
spent the last two years huffing and
speculating wildly about keep in mind
that Michael Cohen is Trump's personal
lawyer of 10 years he now hates Donald
Trump and would like to destroy him he
has said that again and again if Michael
Cohen had the dime he would drop it but
he doesn't there is nothing there it was
all a lie can we go home now
nope we've got two more days of stuff
just like this
two more days of exchanges like this one
where members of Congress feel that
they're not only dumber than you thought
they were but they're a lot creepier can
he be blackmailed because of his
financial and business ventures
including by foreign government is there
a love child there is not to money to
the best of my know you would do you
have any knowledge of President Trump
abusing any control substances I'm not
aware of that no do you have any
knowledge of President Trump arranging
any health care procedures for any women
not in his family I'm not aware of that
No
is there a love child you see a dope
head
did he pay for abortions no no no no no
by the end you start feeling kind of bad
for Michael Cohen honestly he's not a
genius anyone knows him will affirm that
he's in his 50s now and he's headed to
prison and that's a long way from where
he expected to be Cohen showed up in
Washington two years ago anticipating
that he'd be that kind of guy the kind
of mover and shaker who'd be welcome in
any restaurant in town part the Seas for
Michael Cohen now he's gonna be eating
sloppy joes off a metal tray with a
thousand other creeps and identical
polyester uniforms in the lockup
so take the politics out of it for a
minute if you can let's be honest this
is a sad story Michael Cohen is a broken
and desperate man but nobody cares
Democrats cheered for his conviction on
ludicrous absurd campaign finance
charges is it paying off somebody's
girlfriend is a campaign finance
violation it's laughable but they don't
care now they're squeezing whatever use
they can out of Michael Cohen as he
shuffles off to his cell where the rest
of us get out of this we learned that
Trump is vain and vulgar okay what do we
do with that information is it supposed
to make us support open borders late
term abortion the war in Syria the green
New Deal will it make the drug epidemic
go away will it make the suicide rate
drop will it make housing affordable in
the cities what does it have to do with
anything
well doesn't have anything to do with
anything and that is exactly the point
of it that's why this is going on
forever the more time they waste yelping
about Trump's charity auction scam and
is naughty language in private the less
time they have to explain why they've
run this country into the ground and
gotten rich doing it this is a
distraction and we are falling for it
for the record